Величезні пам’ятники, погруддя, монументи і барельєфи -
майже 70 декомунізованих пам’яток радянського тоталітарного мистецтва
зібрали у львівському музеї "Територія Терору".
Серед найвідоміших - "Мати-Батьківщина", "Воїн з прапором",
"Солдат з автоматом", пам’ятник радянській космонавтці.
У Львові декомунізація розпочалася в 90-х роках, у Львові
і Західній Україні. Більшість пам'ятників з того періоду зникли.
Ми маємо лише один в колекції з того періоду, який ми знайшли
випадково – це пам'ятник Василю Пересаді.
Все інше - це те, що вже за останні роки до нас приїхало.
Тобто можна вважати, що найголовніші маркери
радянської влади знесені і перенесені,
демонтовані до нас в музей.
Перший експонат приїхав у музей ще в 2016 році.
Оскільки іншого місця для їхнього зберігання не було.
Та уся ця колекція радянської символіки тут тимчасово.
У майбутньому є ідея перенести пам’ятники радянської спадщини
в окремий музей чи філіал.
І так із 2016-го року до теперішнього, 2023-го року,
до нас поступово звозили всі декомунізовані,
а вже деколонізовані пам'ятники.
Наш музей не пристосований, не було запроєктовано їхнє зберігання,
але тимчасово вони зберігаються на нашій стоянці,
на якій ми зараз знаходимося. Сподіваємося, що в майбутньому
це буде окремий музей, адже ця колекція потребує
окремого місця і показу.
Долю кожного монумента чи скульптури вирішує місцева влада
спільно з управлінням охорони історичного середовища.
Спочатку засідає спеціальна комісія з декомунізації та деколонізації,
яка складається з істориків, музейників, громадських активістів
і місцевої влади. Далі ухвалюють рішення про демонтаж
і перенесення. Але більшість із цих об`єктів вже віджили свій час
і під час демонтажів просто розвалюються.
Вони ж стоять реально 70-80 років, і це не є якісь такі витвори
мистецтва дуже. Це штамповання 99%. За ці роки вони...
Приїжджає спеціаліст, обслідує і знаходить їх.
Вони в тріщинах більшість. До них люди не ходять.
Навіть ті люди, які кажуть: "Залишмо!"…
А ми приїжджаємо на це місце, а там заросло все травою,
ніяких лампадок, нічого. Але так люди звикли. Це звиклість.
Та не завжди процес декомунізації відбувається швидко,
каже голова громадської організації "Деколонізація України"
Вадим Поздняков. За його підрахунками,
в українських містах залишається ще сотні експонатів
радянського минулого.
Дуже багато пам'ятників не можна демонтувати, тому що
дуже неактивно працює Міністерство культури.
Бо без погоджень від Міністерства культури і інформаційної політики
демонтувати той чи інший пам'ятник неможливо.
У нас є купа відповідей від громад, умовно кажучи,
від Закарпаття до Харківщини, які жаліються, що вони пів року тому
чи рік тому надіслали документи, щоб їм дали дозвіл на демонтаж
того чи іншого радянського пам'ятника.
А дозвіл чи якісь погодження вони так досі і не отримали.
Ще сотні-сотні таких доволі великих пам'ятників у доволі великих
містах треба демонтувати. Тобто ми нещодавно робили список
"ТОП-100", і те, дуже багато об'єктів не потрапило в цей список "ТОП-100".
Насправді можна сміливо робити список і "ТОП-500",
бо об'єктів дуже багато, особливо по невеликих містах,
про які мало хто знає теж.
Частину колекції радянської символіки після демонтажу
варто зберегти для майбутніх поколінь,
вважає директорка музею "Територія Терору" Ольга Гончар.
Адже, за її словами, це живі свідки тоталітарного режиму,
правонаступницею якого оголосила себе Росія.
Це, на мою думку, така певна вакцинація від тоталітаризму,
вакцинація для майбутніх поколінь, для нас всіх, тому що
загалом людина дуже швидко все забуває.
І зараз тим більше ми живемо в епоху інфоприводів,
тіктоків, де сьогодні щось відбулося - завтра вже всі про це забули.
А зло змінює свої форми, але воно нікуди не зникає.
А це прекрасні свідки всіх цих страшних подій,
і тому їх потрібно залишати, щоб пам'ятати, що звідки береться,
і до чого воно в результаті приводить, і чому never again стає again and again.
І оце, що передає нам знову вітання.
Ну, я думаю, що це також історія про зло, яке триває,
і про зло, яке не було покаране.
Тому що, на жаль, те, що у нас відбувається, це про зло,
яке продовжується.
Та переважна більшість радянських експонатів не є унікальними,
кажуть експерти. Тому звозити їх усіх в один музей - немає сенсу.
Адже щоб збудувати окремий музей і утримувати тисячі об’єктів
радянської символіки  - треба витрати понад 10 мільйонів гривень.
Це є такі штампування: вони стоять від Калуги до Ужгорода,
від Мукачева до Далекого Сходу. Це однаковісінькі пам'ятники.
Ці всі пам'ятники давно досліджені, сфотографовані і так далі.
Вони не несуть 99% ніякої краси, мистецької якості і так далі.
Зберігати їх ради чого? Ну, я, наприклад, за рік часу,
що я цим займаюся, я змінив свою кардинально думку.
Одна з них - це дійсно фінансова. Заради чого? Щоб показати це кому?
Нашим дітям, внукам, правнукам, яка була окупація?
Ну, є відео, є ще щось. Тобто, є кілька пам'ятників.
Музею терору у Львові вистачить. Зараз навіть мільйон гривень
витрачати на музей, ще один музей - це недоцільно, я вважаю.
Вже б виграли ми війну - могли б на це подивитися.
Я навіть не можу уявити собі якийсь музей в Україні,
який зібрав би стільки цього мотлоху. Тому що, якщо зібрати
всю радянську імперську символіку і туди звезти, то це, напевно,
буде музей з десятків тисяч експонатів, які просто не знаю,
скільки грошей треба було б, аби їх утримувати.
І чи варто утримувати купу штампованих пам'ятників
теж в одному місці.
Є окремі унікальні експонати, які варто зберігати
в музеї, вважає Вадим Поздняков.
Є окремі екземпляри, як, наприклад пам'ятник Артему у Святогірську,
чи оця "Батьківщина-мати" в Києві. Тобто є окремі, унікальні,
одиничні випадки якихось пам'ятників чи там
пам'ятники періоду імперської доби у Полтаві,
які треба музеєфікувати після демонтажу.
Питання в тому, що, в принципі, унікальні пам'ятники,
якісь цікаві, які треба музеєфікувати, є лише в якихось дуже великих
містах, зазвичай це Київ, Харків, Полтава.
І музеєфікувати один-два пам'ятники три громади знайде гроші.
А в переважній більшості малих міст це такі об'єкти,
які або руйнуються під час демонтажу,
або не мають жодної культурної цінності.
Тобто, хіба там продати на металолом, або деякі пам'ятники
просто залізобетонні, це радянські солдати чи якісь Пушкіни
- вони часто розвалюються взагалі навіть під час демонтажу.
Про створення музею тоталітаризму багато говорили в різних містах України.
Та на державному рівні таку ідею поки не втілили.
Я знаю, що в нас постійно, майже кожен рік ведеться дискусія,
що такий музей має бути створений в Києві.
То Мінкульт підіймає цю тему, чи то Інститут національної пам'яті.
Але, наскільки я знаю, у Києві, на жаль, більшість монументів десь,
ніхто за тим не слідкував… І з чого робити музей - це знак питання.
Тобто тут ми у Львові можемо спокійно сказати,
що в нас є колекція з найголовнішими об'єктами з міста.
Тобто якщо рано чи пізно такий музей буде, ми вже певні дискусії
ведемо в наших колах, то нам принаймні є,
з чого той музей зробити.
Нам не потрібен музей тоталітаризму в кожній області.
Для нас, перепрошую, це не сильно актуально робити саме
в кожній області, щоб кожна область витрачала гроші на його утримання.
А ось якби у нас був один дуже потужний.
Може він буде в Путивлі, може, якщо він буде державним,
держава десь його під Київ всі ці об'єкти перевезе - ми не знаємо.
Це має все ж таки, на мою особисту думку, після перемоги
бути створено структуру при Мінкульті чи
Інституті національної пам'яті, яка буде опікуватись
уже офіційним створенням державного музею.
Тоді й варто, на думку експертів, вирішити, куди звезти всі ці
пам’ятники радянської епохи і яку концепцію музею придумати.
Після перемоги можна вирішувати, яка концепція, куди, що, як.
Бо коли ми зітремо всю радянщину, як ми маємо зробити,
і діти нинішнього покоління вже близько не знають,
що таке Радянський Союз. Їм треба пояснювати, чому це не ок,
чому комуністичні ідеї це не ок.
Якраз поїздки в такий музей з поясненням, хто такий пан Ленін,
Дзержинський, що вони робили на території України.
І там розкуркулення, Голодомор і таке інше.
Школярі б дізналися про те, що комунізм - це не ок,
радянщина - це не ок.